cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com ladies and gentlemen uh I
think Joe Biden's gonna drop up I think
it is fair to say Joe Biden will drop
out that's that's that is a strong
opinion I'm having
Nancy Pelosi concedes Biden may drop out
of the 2024 race then laughs and refuses
to say if Kamala Harris is the best
running mate because this was I believe
this was on CNN Anderson Cooper is
asking these questions and when asked if
Biden is going to continue running is
any chance that Biden does not continue
running says I hope not
it's actually a possibility now thinking
about all of the scandals we've seen so
far
and impeachment
they need Biden to drop out they need
distractions for this and and and we all
know it I mean there's no reasonable
person not even not even the majority of
Democrats the majority of Democrats are
saying he can't run he's too old what
does that look like then like explain
the process then if he says I'm not
running so then do they do a primary do
they just appoint somebody what do they
do well depends on how conspirate
conspiracy-minded you are if you would
say I'm low low conspiracy mind is Joe
Biden is Rife with political scandals
facing an impeachment which everyone
thinks is going to be inevitable and
he's too old the polls show he's too old
so Joe Biden will be asked Joe it's time
to to get a new a new team in here
because we're not gonna be able to beat
Trump off of your ticket that's the low
conspiracy mind and then Gavin Newsom
says if y'all are willing to have me
shakes Joe Biden's hand and says I'm
willing to to fight for this country and
then but DNC just installs him as the
candidate no primary or something Joe
Biden says look you know I'm an old
man and I think handing this off to
Gavin Newsom is the right right approach
and something like that and Kamala
Harris says that she's not you know she
she's done what she had to do and she
was here for for team Biden and she's
only team Biden and she understands that
if I'm not interested she's not going to
be here that's local conspiracy mind
seems
difficult to imagine something like that
high conspiracy mind is
powerful interests don't want Joe Biden
to run and want a clean path forward
which is not Joe Biden coming out and
just bowing out because that makes the
DNC look weak look at makes Democrats
look weak High conspiracy mind in my
view would be Joe Biden suffers a
medical issue Gavin Newsom runs out on
stage and starts giving him CPR saves
the life of the president and then the
media does this press tour of Gavin
Newsom the man who saved the President
Joe Biden can then say like after this
medical episode I don't think it is
appropriate to pursue this uh Kamala can
then say something like you know I was
here for team Biden and I'm going to
stick with him if he's bowing out I want
to make sure that I'm working with him
on whatever he needs to assist him and
we want to pass the torch to Gavin and a
new team or whatever and that's high
conspiracy I pictured the most cringe
Time Magazine cover of Gavin Newsom
looking off at an angle and it's saying
the man who saved democracy he has the
most plastic looking and then there will
be a tagline where it's like facing the
facing the collapse of our of our of our
democracy from fascist threats like
Donald Trump Gavin Newsom saved the one
man who fought who who gavinism saved
the man who saved the country and in
turn took up the mantle to save the
country himself something like that yeah
and there are and all these editors are
sitting there being like I can picture
it right here
are there any Pathways where Kamala
fights for a spot
oh yeah I mean there's a million
Pathways I'm just saying like
the the the reasonable approach
any smart Democrat we've seen the New
York Times The Washington Post both be
like Joe Biden probably shouldn't run so
when you've got the media saying this
stuff you've got the majority of that
it's like 70 some odd percent of
Democrats polled say he's too old to be
president
any any Democrat worth worth their job
is saying we can't run Joe Biden how do
we get him out of the race
and so I got to tell you my conspiracy
theory it's not really conspiracy I'm
just saying the best way to get Gavin
Newsom in and to get Biden Kamala out is
Biden is at a rally in California for
his campaign and then grips his chest as
a public collapse collapses Gavin Newsom
runs full speed under stage throws his
coat off checks his vitals provides CPR
Maddox come in Secret Service secures
the area
magically the TV cameras are told not to
cut away yep all the cameras they
normally would be all live so
it's in the buildings come down in free
fall it's a bit too movie-ask and
conspiratorial like but I got to tell
you if there was like an evil Shadow
organization of unlimited resources
plotting how you do this perfectly
that's it because then Gavin knows him
is on the cover of Time Magazine the man
who saved democracy Joe bidenvalently
saved this country in 2020 Gavin Newsom
just saved him like it writes itself and
then and then he Gavin do some sort of
press tour he's on The View he's on real
time he's on every nightly show and
you've got Anderson Cooper being like
Governor Newsom
what is it like to be the man who saved
the president and then Gavin's just like
look
I'm not here to be a hero I'm just here
to do the right thing that any good
red-blooded American would do when faced
with someone in need Define San
Francisco and then but this this kind of
story you know we were talking earlier
about your leftist friends your Lefty
friends who don't pay attention to
what's going on
you would go to them and be like yes but
in California there's human waste all
over the ground and they'll be like stop
insulting the man to save the President
right right it exonerates all his sins
basically it makes him this hero but I I
I would like to figure out what's with
Kamala in this scenario and we've talked
about you know maybe she would be
offered a position in the Supreme Court
or they could they could well this was
actually easy uh after Gavin Newsom
saves Joe Biden Kamala walks on the
stage on the stage and says uh I must go
now my home planet needs me and then she
just lifts off and down his face
I've actually always wanted to be
governor of California so let's just
switch things yeah she's like that is
that but that is the the most difficult
thing in trying to come up with how
Kamala Harris is is to bows out yeah it
could really be her saying that she
doesn't know if she can she was
committed to team biting because of how
much she believed in him and she doesn't
know if it if she's capable of or if
it's or if it's reasonable too and she
could do this thing where she's like
look she'd get wrecked by the feminist
for saying that though well no she she
could she she could say something where
she tries to look humble and say I I
don't know if I would provide enough for
a winning ticket I was with I was 14
Biden and that team is is unfortunately
broken by this incident and I want to
make sure we win this one and you know
there's questions about electability and
polling I I say the demo the Democratic
party show the primary and find the best
people for the job it would come off as
humble yeah and and and look the polls
show she cannot win but she couldn't
have a job in politics in it I don't
think she's ready to to type it but I'm
not talking about the real world oh yeah
I'm like the most magical scenario yeah
I think the other one would be if she
pulled Sandra O'Connor and her husband
is suddenly mysteriously ill and she
feels as though she needs to go spend
time with him and just side steps out of
politics because the only problem with
the one you presented to me is that the
feminist will be like you're a girl boss
you can do anything what do you mean you
don't think that doesn't really matter
for it matters for her and for her
Legacy that's that's what she wants to
be maybe speaking to him maybe
she marries Joe Biden and then when he
gets sick she's like my husband needs me
Jill's listening she's like that one
step too far Tim no I have been in here
for too long I've been paying my debts I
think realistically Joe will not can he
will not give it up I actually I don't
know he they can convince him to maybe
they can come in and sit him down and be
like it's not happening dude no you're
not gonna destroy our democracy Let It
Go you're a liability you gotta let it
go and he's got like nine guys around
them all telling him that he might be
like okay for the party I'll step down
maybe but then who's gonna be it's got
to be I think he's too power hungry I
think he would yeah so he's got to be
tired at this point I mean he's 80 and
he's I I don't know I don't know what
they do to Hype them up every now and
then so that he's like firing on all
synapses but I just think on those
synapses yeah I I don't know I don't
know I just think he he might be ready
for a break maybe yeah but he didn't run
in 2016. it's been a one one-term
President right could have said you know
I've served my moment and we're out we
got away from Big Bad Donald Trump and
so now I'm ready for a younger
generation to step in he could have said
that he kept saying we need younger
people I mean Mitt Romney just made this
announcement saying if I run again I'll
be in my mid-80s and I think young
people need Joe Biden could have said
this he chose not to and I think that's
because he doesn't want to give it up he
doesn't and if he runs again it's gonna
they're gonna make him debate the media
or they're gonna start insulting him and
calling out his crimes and probably
imprison him without media coverage it
reminds me of the conversations around
uh Dianne Feinstein and like how they're
saying you know all these organizations
again feminist organizations in
particular are saying you know you did
so much for us thank you for your time
we really wish you would leave yeah they
said similar things about Ruth Bader
gainsburg they said you know there was a
whole conversation about whether or not
she should retire because her Legacy and
this and the other and they wanted
someone to be appointed under uh not
Trump basically and uh
that didn't work out waited too long if
they if buying if they make Biden debate
if he refuses to step down he debates
Gavin Newsom it's gonna rip the
Democratic party apart it'll shred their
ability to win an election I can't
imagine that having that kind of come
like con conflict within the party would
be good for their for their message and
then that would I mean obviously I think
they're going to take Trump off the
ballot in a couple of states and make it
so I can't win a bunch of people in the
Republican Party are going to vote for
him anyway and split the Republican
party all up too so we could end up
seeing like 20 for Vivek 32 for Donald
Trump 31 for Gavin Newsom 24 21 for
Biden like who knows should be crazy but
then I I would not be surprised if a
secretary of state in a swing state in
October of next year or or September
removes his name from the ballot and
says sue me maybe I should stop saying
that it will happen though because I
don't want to be black pilled and
encouraged that dis reputable or just
you know just disgusting Behavior like
let the people vote yeah unless there's
actual legal precedent to remove him
um
you got you let the people vote they're
gonna vote for him anyway no write them
in there's there are too many voters
that just check Republican or Democrat
and so if they take Trump's name off the
ballot and and it's not here's another
thing his his name could be off the
ballot in key counties we saw Arizona
this could be a trial balloon in Arizona
we know it is definitive it is proven
Beyond a reasonable doubt it is fact
it's in the news the wrong sized ballots
were printed on wrong sized paper so the
machines could not read them they'll
argue it didn't change anything and that
is the most psychotic and absurd lie the
machines are broken at hundreds of
locations of course that changes things
there's no question about that but
they're lying because it's what they do
where was the remedy for these broken
bouts I I really don't understand like
if I was a judge and someone came to me
and said these ballots couldn't be
scanned by the machine I'd be like
election overturned done no question
it's not I like but all these judges are
cowards and and pathetic and they're
weak and it was like I don't want to be
the one to say it yes it's because
they're being ponderous judges best case
scenario they're cowards worst case
scenario there's behind the oh there
ain't on it deals and stuff yeah if if
we're supposed to have an election and
the and the ballots at several hundred
locations are wrong or however many
locations that's it sorry guys it's a
do-over don't know don't care it's your
problem you deal with it we will not
have to have a special election we'll
determine what an adequate amount of
time is for preparation for you but
the the state screwed up the election
process and it should not stand but they
didn't do that so the trial balloon is
good come uh 2024 don't be surprised if
ballots are printed on wrong paper or
Trump's smudged or not included on it
and they'll say sue us I was talking to
my Uber driver today uh very interesting
and just asking him lots of questions
and you know what's the problem this
country oh we're so polarized how did
that happen Trump
and I'm like really you think that Trump
is just a one-word answer yeah no he
said and we have to get rid of him and I
said how do you do that also he's not
president right now so right but he said
better right and I I was just amazed um
I just asking less we have to give it
how do you do that legally and he goes
well they're working on it but even if
they can't do it legally he just needs
to go and it was like it just blew me
away and this was a guy who was a cult
pretty sensible uh I have no response
like no reason for you they'll just say
he has to go and then ask why and
they'll be like well you know just
because like you know the thing like you
know because you know what he said is
because he's tearing families apart yeah
he's telling friendships apart and I'm
like you think that started with Trump
and he's like oh absolutely so we will
not have wholeness in this country until
he's gone that's yeah it started when he
was on The Apprentice he was just
wrecking family if you illegally got rid
of one of the most famous politicians in
the United States before he's about to
run for president you would not rebind
the United States that would tear it to
shreds I don't know what this guy's
thinking that's it's a cult no he is
getting he is getting one half well he's
getting a narrative and and he believes
it and so that's the conclusion so
anyway if you're a judge with that
narrative and you have the power to do
something about it what are you gonna do
yeah I don't know I think it's difficult
I think there are people on both sides
who feel the division and want truly and
honestly want to see that healed on the
other hand it's very hard to reconcile
opposite sides when one of them is
saying
getting rid of trump is the only answer
in fact he will always have a political
Legacy in this in this country even if
you know for whatever reason something
happened he weren't to win the election
in 2024 he has already made an impact so
are you saying that it there's no
turning back that because there really
is no ultimately getting rid of trump he
is already a staple in American politics
he made a huge impact on our history you
have to be able to heal the wounds
regardless of who was in in the Oval
Office yeah well anyway I argued look
I feel like the sea change happened with
Obama personally and that was when I was
not a political animal it wasn't well to
me that was the first time when I heard
the other side saying um it's not that
we disagree it's not even that you're
stupid it's that you're evil you're evil
right now it's your Nazis your bigots
you're evil if you don't agree with our
Progressive priorities and you know you
can have relationships with people that
are wrong or misguided or stupid but you
don't have relationships with Nazis yeah
but they're evil
who the the the elements of the left
that are pushing their political agenda
you have the malicious evil and you have
the banality of evil the people who
March in lockstep uh so I'll give you a
couple examples literally not everybody
is evil but when you have someone say to
me I think the general direction that
the j6 trials are going is good right
and I say Joe Biggs got two decades for
not for allegedly knocking over a
temporary barricade and they say I don't
know anything about that but I think
it's mostly good that's the banality of
evil when it's commonplace that ignorant
people allow evil things to happen but
you then have the people who are running
the show the intelligence agencies the
prosecutors and the courts that no
there's no reason to give someone like
Joe Biggs two decades for knocking over
a barricade that's that's ridiculous but
they're evil and they want you to suffer
they want you to feel pain these are
people like you know the funny thing
about uh video games I made a joke about
Baldur's Gate
most people who play video games will
understand this there are many games
that have Karma systems where you can
choose to be good or evil and the meme
online is that whenever people try to
play the evil character it hurts and
they can't do it they can't bring
themselves to play the evil character
unfortunately for you some people have
figured out how to do it in real life
the guy who why does it hurt
okay so uh Baldur's Gate for instance or
I.E Fallout three
Fallout 3 uh has a uh
right when you come out of the in the
beginning there's a town that's that's
built around a nuclear bomb fall three
is a game about a post-apocalyptic which
Obama never went off yeah it's a it's
like a Megaton bomb and very easily you
can disarm it or you can trigger it to
blow up killing everybody and it just
does it feels bad it feels bad to be
like I know none of these things these
people are real but I don't I can't so
what you the joke is you save do it and
then load and having never actually done
it just to see what would happen but
there's a bunch of memes where uh I mean
if you read stories about these video
games people struggle to be the villain
in the game so it's like
um in Baldur's Gate I don't want to
spoil anything but let's just say I'll
give a really Bland hypothetical the bad
guy looks at you and says slay the
innocent person and you can choose to do
it and most people like I I can't I'm
trying to play a villain character for
the villain storyline but it just you
can't bring yourself to just watch this
scene where it's a representation of you
hurting innocent people so it doesn't
look like you do you look like yourself
okay and then is the person that you're
hurting do they look like a real person
be a goblin could be a unicorn who knows
it could be random it's still pretty
cartoony at this stage oh yeah but but
it's it's not that it's my point with
this is not to get into video games and
all this stuff it's just that it will
start to look very real though the
people who understand what I'm talking
about if you don't you know just just
try and imagine the scenario but for
people who've played video games and
know that you're like I can't bring
myself to be the evil character
there's a the guy in Virginia whose
daughter was raped or sexually assaulted
and he was at a hearing oh when a woman
yeah yeah and a woman said to him you're
lying that never happened and then the
school board lied and said it never
happened and he lost it he got angry
yeah the prosecutor tried to put him in
jail and he said she is the most evil
person I've ever met we are dealing with
these prosecutors
this woman in in Virginia
knows that a man's daughter was sexually
assaulted in a school
she knows they're covering it up and in
her mind she goes I'm gonna put you in
prison because they they get this sick
pleasure from just hurting people it's
an unfathomable I cannot understand it
but that characterizes a substantial
amount of people in what we would call
the culture War left whereas the culture
we're right certainly does have these
people too but it's an inversion there's
much less of them they're less tolerated
people don't like that stuff on the left
you have the banality of evil the people
who March in lockstep not asking
questions about why you put someone in
prison for 20 years and then the evil
person is empowered by the ignorant to
to torture individuals thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time